BACK THE [bleep] UP
WITH THOSE CAM GLASSES?
- FIRST OF ALL,
THEY'RE CALLED "SPYFOCALS."
SECOND OF ALL...
THESE BAD BOYS
ARE GOING
TO CHANGE THE WAY
PEOPLE SEE MOVIES.
FINALLY, THE AUDIENCE WILL BE
ABLE TO SEE WHAT MAN SEES!
HOW MAN SEES, YOU KNOW?
- ALL RIGHT.
ALL RIGHT.
EASY, JIM CAMERON.
- YEAH.
- I'M PRETTY SURE THEY ALREADY
USED THAT P.O.V. STYLE
IN PORNO.
STREET BLOW JOBS.
YOU'VE SEEN IT.
WE'VE SEEN IT.
WE'VE WATCHED IT TOGETHER.
- I LOVE IT.
- HEY! YOU GUYS SAID YOU
NEEDED LIGHTING FOR YOUR MOVIE,
SO I BROUGHT A LAVA, STROBE,
BLACK LIGHT.
- OH.
- HELL, YEAH.
- NONE OF THOSE SOUND
VERY HELPFUL.
- SPYFOCALS?
- YEAH.
- OH, MY GOD,
YOU GUYS ARE SHOOTING
POV PORNOG, HUH?
- NO--
- THAT'S WHAT
WE WERE JUST SAYING.
- NO, NO. DON'T TELL ME.
I LOVE SURPRISES.
- OKAY.
- I SHOULDN'T HAVE TO SAY THIS.
WE'RE NOT FILMING A PORNO.
- WELL, WE MIGHT HAVE TO,
BECAUSE I DON'T WANT
TO SHOOT ALICE'S DUMB,
STUPID SCRIPT.
- IT'S REALLY DUMB.
IT'S REALLY STUPID.
I THINK WE SHOULD DO
OUR OWN ORIGINAL IDEA, MAN.
- OKAY, YES. NO.
WE'RE GONNA DO OUR MOVIE.
NOT ALICE'S.
NOT A PORNO.
- OKAY, WELL--
- BUT WE'RE GONNA TAKE IT
TO T.A.C.
PEOPLE'LL BE LIKE, "OH, MY GOD.
YOU GUYS MADE THAT?"
AND WE'LL BE LIKE,
"YEAH, STUPID."
NEXT STEP, SUNDANCE!
- WHOA!
- OOH.
- WHERE CHICKS SKI DOWN
MOUNTAINS WITH THEIR BOOBS OUT.
TRUE STORY.
- THAT'S A REAL THING
THAT HAPPENS.
- AT SUNDANCE.
- I HEARD SANDRA BULLOCK
GOT CARPAL TUNNEL SYNDROME
FROM SKI-POLING
THE COEN BROTHERS.
- YEAH.
- YEAH. THAT'S--YOU KNOW,
YOU KNOW THAT ACTION.
LIKE...
- SUNDANCE.
- YEAH. COOL THREE-WAY.
- THAT'S AT SUNDANCE.
THAT'S COOL THAT IT'S, LIKE,
A FILM FESTIVAL.
- YEAH.
- I ALWAYS THOUGHT IT WAS, LIKE,
A DANCE THAT YOU TOOK
YOUR MOM TO,
AND I DID THAT.
I'VE ALREADY BEEN THERE.
I'VE DONE THAT. JUNIOR PROM.
- NO, NO.
IT'S NOT THAT.
- MY MOM GETS LOW, DUDE.